welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today I
started today's show by talking about
the state of Florida and the primary
victories down there and Andrew Gilliam
and Sean Shaw and how great that is
but there's also a lot of horrible right
now in the state of Florida and some of
it does go back to that primary rick
Scott our current Republican governor
did win the primary on the Republican
side so he is now our Republican nominee
for Senate he is going up against
Democratic incumbent Bill Nelson and
believe it or not one of the biggest
issues that these two men will be
fighting about in this election coming
up something they've been fighting about
for a couple months now is toxic algae
this story hasn't gotten a ton of
national attention toxic algae is not
exactly a sexy thing that's going to get
a ton of clicks or a ton of viewers but
it's a very real issue down here in the
state of Florida here's what happens and
and it's kind of a complicated thing so
I'm gonna explain it as simply as
possible
massive lake down in South Florida Lake
Okeechobee probably heard of it every
year during the rainy season levels of
the lake get too high so the state comes
in and drains the water to separate
lakes one on each side one going to the
Gulf of Mexico one going to the Atlantic
Ocean that keeps the lake levels down
what also comes into the lake in
addition to the rain water is toxic
discharge from sugar mills see South
Florida and this is something most
people don't know they don't even think
about it
we still have those sugar barons down
here in Florida they control a lot of
the politics they throw around millions
upon millions of dollars and their
factories release toxic discharges and
they go directly into Lake Okeechobee
and when you get that sugary toxic
discharge it creates toxic algae and
that's what happens so when this toxic
algae begins blooming in Lake Okeechobee
and then it is funneled out through
those Lakes to the Gulf and the Atlantic
you end up with toxic algae all along
shorelines which is what's happening now
except for this year that toxic algae
met up with a red tide so we now have
this massive combination of red tide and
toxic algae that have married together
and created this a massive amount of
toxicity all along Florida's coastlines
if you're not familiar with the state of
Florida you need to understand that our
coastlines are our number one source of
revenue as a state tourism is the
biggest industry here in the state and
yeah we've got Disney World and
Universal and all that that accounts for
a lot but most people are actually going
to the beaches they're coming for the
nice weather now they can't do that
tourism industry is losing a ton of
money because of these toxic algae
blooms property values along the
coastline are plummeting and people are
getting sick from doing nothing more
than standing on the beach and breathing
breathing is getting people sick in
Florida because of this toxic algae
discharge so there's the back story
that's why the algae is here that's how
it got so bad oh and by the way this is
worth mentioning those two lakes where
we funnel all that water out of Lake
Okeechobee there's no life in it there's
no fish there's no other animals it they
are so toxic because of the the
discharge each year nothing can live in
them if you took a fish and put it in
that river it would die so that's how
toxic that is so anyway bringing it back
to the campaign for several months now
Bill Nelson and Rick Scott have been
arguing back and forth about who's to
blame because Bill Nelson takes a lot of
money from the sugar Barons the sugar
Barons are the ones who are creating
this toxicity which breeds the algae bad
on Nelson
but recently major story came out
talking about how rick Scott as governor
of Florida cut 700 million dollars from
the budget of state environmental
agencies that are actually in charge of
monitoring and hand
the toxic algae outbreaks so yes while
it is bad that Nelson is taking money
from the people who are creating the
problem rick Scott took money away from
the people who are supposed to fix the
problem
700 million so Rick Scott stripped away
more money than Bill Nelson took from
his sugar buddies and the sugar people
are also funding Republicans they've
given money to Rick Scott so that's also
kind of a wash there so if you had to
put a blame percentage on this you could
probably easily throw around about 90%
on rick Scott if not more maybe 10% on
Bill Nelson but here's the kicker rick
Scott as the two-term governor of the
state of Florida who's hitting the end
of his a term limited time here
he's cutting money from environmental
protection here in the state of Florida
a state that is 100% dependent upon
environmental tourism and he thinks we
don't need to protect this so can you
imagine the kind of damage this man
would do in the US Senate because at
that point he doesn't just get to make
rules for Florida no he gets to
influence rules for everybody so any
area dependent upon having a clean
environment is at risk if rick Scott
goes to the Senate there is a lot riding
on this Senate race down here in the
state of Florida and though I am NOT a
huge bill Nelson fan I will tell you
that he is a thousand times better than
Rick Scott who by the way happens to be
a guy who committed one of the largest
Medicaid Medicare frauds in the history
of the federal government more than a
billion dollars only managed to keep
himself out of prison by pleading the
fifth amendment more than 70 times
during depositions it's bad enough that
we had him as our governor for two terms
because the people down here don't
really vote in the right way but it
would be even worse to send him to the
US Senate where he would team up with
Marco Rubio and god only knows what kind
of damage those two guys would inflict